e eu queria começar a fazer uma pergunta
pra vocês
pergunta é qual inteligente você é tão
levantei a mão se você acha que você é
abaixo da média inteligência
agora levante a mão se você acha que
você é na média inteligência e
finalmente levante a mão se você acha
que você é acima da média e inteligência
tipicamente as pessoas muitas pessoas
levantam a mão nessa hora acima da média
talvez porque vocês são bastante
inteligente vocês têm notado que estava
fazendo mas a maior parte das pessoas
sugere que está acima da média
inteligência o que é impossível porque a
gente tem que redefinir a média está
todo mundo em cima da média a gente
define a média está todo na média de
novo a gente sabe que é a inteligência
segue uma distribuição muito
característica que a distribuição normal
a maior parte das pessoas está aqui na
média em algumas pessoas estão acima e
outros estão abaixo da média
outro exemplo clássico disso a direção é
a habilidade de dirigir
quando você pergunta às pessoas
sobretudo homens com bem eles dirigem
eles tendem a superestimar as suas
habilidades e se já foi feito em vários
países
você faz um estudo em que você pega as
pessoas mas ali fala favor se
identifique se você acha que um grupo de
30 pessoas se você tá nos top 50 por
cento da segurança da direção se o
motorista seguir ou não
e dependendo do país número varia de 75
85% das pessoas falando que são os 50
melhores por cento motoristas daquela
sala e por definição a muitas pessoas
estão erradas
matematicamente impossível que todos
estejam certos
e eu gosto de falar disso para ilustrar
um princípio que esse princípio que a
gente tende a acreditar que a gente é
melhor do que a gente realmente é uma
coisa bastante universal humana um viés
positivo que a gente tem um outro
exemplo disso é um exemplo tragicômico é
é um texto que foi publicado na véspera
de brasil e alemanha
é um excelente exemplo de pouca
consciência eu tomei cuidado e tomar
cuidado de preservar a identidade do
jornalista para não destruir a carreira
dele é mais diz ele que o brasil é
favorito contra a alemanha e se falava
na véspera
jogo é a melhor parte do texto é assim o
brasil tem o melhor sistema defensivo do
mundo e conhece bem os alemães que vocês
saibam que aconteceu naquele jogo é
então acho que é um exemplo também bem
bem característico do que a gente faz a
nossa dificuldade em conseguir avaliar
nossa habilidade de maneira precisa é a
gente sabe no entanto até pelos exemplos
que eu dei que existe uma relação muito
consistente entre auto consciência e
depressão
essas duas coisas caminham juntas e
tipicamente quanto maior a sua
consciência na hora só depressão o mais
triste você fica isso é bastante
intuitivo
pense na última vez que vocês se olhar
no espelho e descobriram algo que vocês
não gostaram
vocês tomaram consciência de algo que
não gostaram e se tipicamente levam
estado de humor negativo quem sabe que
essa é uma relação muito consistente a
gente vê isso em vários pacientes vários
grupos de pacientes em pessoas também
sem nenhuma condição psiquiátrica ou
neurológica
a grande discussão é qual é a relação de
causalidade o que causa o que elas
caminham juntas
será que na verdade a autoconsciência
causa depressão será que nessa direção
relação de causalidade
é isso é bastante intuitivo é o que eu
falava antes sobre tomar consciência de
algo e ficar triste com esse algo ou
pelo seu humor piorado por conta disso
achamos o princípio de calvin por causa
dessa tirinhas genial ele fala não é
negação eu sou apenas muito seletivos
sobre a realidade que eu aceito
notem muito importante o estado de humor
dele nesse estado de negação que ele
mesmo nega é um estado alegre
isso reforça que eu falei aqui sobre
essa relação consistente uma ideia um
pouco menos intuitiva é de que a
depressão causa ou de consciência é um
pouco diferente é ea gente dá o nome
disso de realismo depressivo eu sou um
especialista em autismo regressivo
porque sou botafoguense
estou muito familiarizado com esse mas a
idéia é a seguinte a idéia é que você é
ao ficar deprimido perde todos aqueles
viés dispositivos que você tinha antes
você tipicamente têm viés positivo
tipicamente você vê as coisas de uma
maneira mais positiva que a medição
você acha que dirige muito bem o que é
muito inteligente e quando você fica
deprimido você perde isso que a lei de ó
diz ele e notem de novo estado de humor
dele é o contraste entre os estados de
humor é muito importante dizer e nem
todos podemos ver alguns de nós não
conseguem isso é tudo é é uma conclusão
bastante é deprimente mas é uma coisa
que a gente sabe que tem um evidências
empíricas pra isso faz a gente conseguir
de fato ver as coisas com mais precisão
e clareza em estado de humor é negativos
seria ótimo se a gente pudesse na
verdade para descobrir essa relação de
causalidade
seria ótimo se pudesse fazer um
experimento que a gente pudesse
manipular o estado de humor das pessoas
e ver se a autoconsciência muda mas a
verdade é que a gente já tem esse
experimento e é um experimento natural e
um grupo com o trabalho muito que são os
pacientes com transtorno bipolar
essas pessoas são pessoas que de uma
semana para a outra
vão ter uma alteração do seu estado de
humor e quando elas têm essa alteração
tipicamente autoconsciência delas muda
também é ea gente sabe depois de vários
estudos de conduzir uma sequência de
estudos
a gente sabe que quanto maior a mania
quanto mais mania que o paciente com
transtorno bipolar ele está menor
autoconsciência dele perde a consciência
e é muito notável isso publicamente
porque aquele mesmo paciente que na
semana anterior
reconhecida é um problema que conhecia
ter dificuldades procuravam tratamento
tomava medicação partir do momento que
ele está em estado maníaco ele acha que
ele não tem problemas
acho que não está mais agitado e é isso
uma conseqüência clínica muito grande
porque porque ele vai se tratar se ele
não tem uma condição que a gente
realizou uma série de estudos e está
trazendo evidências muito interessantes
como fazer o manejo desses pacientes
como lidar com esses pacientes e tem
grandes implicações para o diagnóstico
dos pacientes também um outro campo que
o trabalho é um campo que é é muito caro
pra mim a questão da autoconsciência
demência em pessoas mais velhas que têm
um processo demencial o que acontece com
auto consciência delas a gente sabe que
a você ter consciência de aula
você precisa de funções cognitivas
preservadas e é a demência caracterizada
por mudanças estruturais no cérebro que
são é muito marcadas e aqui no slide tem
uma comparação de um cérebro de um idoso
saudável com o cérebro de uma pessoa com
quadro demencial avançado e as duas
coisas que são mais fácil de notar a
primeira essa atrofia cortical e o
córtex essa região mais nova do cérebro
é que é responsável pelas funções mais
complexas incluindo auto consciência e
outra uma atrofia muito marcada do
hipocampo que essa região aqui que aqui
é quase desaparece no final de um
processo demencial que é como vocês não
devem surpreender é responsável pela
memória é é a grande questão é como você
pode ter auto consciência e saber quem
você é e quais são as suas habilidades
se você não tem memória e eu queria
mostrar isso com o caso de uma paciente
é inglesa é que o atende no contexto de
uma pesquisa via no contexto da pesquisa
ela é tinha pouquíssimo a consciência da
sua condição
isso é bem característica pessoas com
demência você pergunta pra elas
você tem um problema de saúde vão falar
não é sempre a memória não me à memória
não é brilhante mas eu também tenho 80
anos o que você poderia esperar disso no
caso dela tinha pouquíssimas clareza
sobre o conca pais na hora de fazer as
coisas
e qual o nível de comprometimento de
memória que ela tinha quando perguntado
no entanto no meio da entrevista ela
conseguiu recordar que alguém tenha dado
essa informação pra ela eu perguntei
para ela se ela tinha um problema de
saúde que é uma pergunta que é muito
difícil que as pessoas que nem respondo
que sim você tem um problema de saúde
uma condição clínica ela falou eu acho
que sim
eu acho que já me falaram sobre isso eu
acho que anotaram pra mim ela foi buscar
nos papéis dela e achou um papelzinho
que estava escrito que ela tinha
demência não olha eu tenho tendência
está escrito aqui
ela guardou o papel de meia hora depois
mais adiante na sessão quando perguntado
novamente se ela tinha um problema de
saúde ela já não conseguia mais lembrar
disso
então o que acontece com muitos desses
pacientes com demência é que ele existe
qessem que eles esquecem das coisas
eles não conseguem consolidar essa
informação e em função disso
joão consegue atualizar o seu próprio
conceito e não conseguem ter plena
consciência das suas habilidades é a um
campo no entanto que o campo é novo e
fascinante sobre isso que é o campo da
reatividade implícita são as evidências
que sugerem que a despeito de muitos
pacientes psiquiátricos e neurológicos
não terem com consciência do seu estado
eles podem processar informações de
maneira não consciente é isso abre um
caminho muito vasto pra gente na clínica
jeito de cuidar das pessoas um caminho
muito interessante muito fértil e eu
conduzi um desses estudos justamente na
dance
nesse estudo eu é pedir para as pessoas
fazerem uma tarefa de computador e era
uma tarefa que tinha dificuldade
controlada então já sabia com bem eles
iriam na tarefa era uma tarefa difícil e
é as pessoas faziam os participantes
faziam a tarefa e eu é filmava as
expressões faciais das pessoas enquanto
elas fazem uma tarefa e é tipicamente as
pessoas com demência tinham pouca
clareza de com laura e foram na tarefa
todos falavam que foram muito melhores
na tarefa do que realmente foram mas
quando você olhava as expressões faciais
eles estavam muito assustados
envergonhados desapontados todas as
emoções que a gente tem diante de uma
performance que não é adequada o que
sugeria que algum nível de processar
essa informação e nos tratava nesse caso
de negação porque eles também tinham
dificuldade de processar informações
quando iam bem mas ainda assim ficavam
felizes
eu acho que o que acontece nesse caso é
ilustrativo de uma característica
fascinante do cérebro é ao longo do seu
desenvolvimento o cérebro o
desenvolvimento das espécies é o cérebro
ele se desenvolveu por acúmulo
superposição de camadas e não
substituição então as estruturas não iam
sendo substituídos vão sendo colocadas
umas em cima das outras
é o resultado disso é que nós temos os
mais diferentes tipos de informação
vários caminhos caminhos paralelos
alguns dos quais não passam pela
consciência
então por exemplo se uma cobra aparece
nessa sala ainda que conscientemente a
gente
veja cobre tem uma reação antes de ter
consciência disso
só de ver uma coisa se mexendo a gente
já tomou um susto no nosso coração já
bate mais rápido e se tem um exemplo
cotidiano que é muito bom pra pensar
isso que quando a gente vê algo se
mexendo a gente ver uma sombra e tomou
um susto é por conta desse processamento
não consciente que é mais antigo que é
muito rápido e você tem todos esses
caminhos paralelos
esse é o mapa esquemático né da
processamento visual do macaco reso
importante aqui não é ficar pensando em
todas as áreas as mais diferentes áreas
mas pensar em todas essas linhas porque
todas essas linhas são diferentes
conexões de forma que você perde algumas
que estão envolvidas com o processo de
auto consciência você tem outros que não
são conscientes e esse é um caso muito
interessante pra gente
do ponto de vista clínico é tem uma
outra paciente que eu queria trazer a
história dela porque acho que ilustra
muito bem isso
ela fez essa tarefa de computador e
ficou frustrado disse mas ao final falou
que foi muito bem na tarefa é muito
melhor do que eu realmente tinha ido mas
o que era notado nela era como a
despeito de falar que ela não tinha
tendência é que ela não tinha problemas
de memória ela espalhou várias notinhas
na casa dela com instruções de como
fazer as coisas
ela tinha passado a usar muito mais o
calendário agenda acertar nos seus
amigos o que demonstrava que em algum
nível essa informação está presente
a gente acha que esse nível é um nível
não consciente é não necessariamente
ligada à negação necessariamente ligada
uma defesa psicológica mais ligado a
essa característica do cérebro e como
falei antes disso acho que traz uma
responsabilidade muito grande pra gente
porque isso sugere que mesmo quando as
pessoas parecem não saber o que está
acontecendo
elas podem estar processando isso
sobretudo essas informações de caráter
afetivo
então isso convoca faz com que a gente
tem que pensar o cuidado dessas pessoas
de outra maneira a gente processa tanta
informação as informação tão rica sobre
como a gente está sentindo de maneira
não consentia forma com a gente se
comunica com as pessoas tocam as pessoas
e eu acho que não é só o paciente não só
um paciente neurológico e psiquiátrico
mas as pessoas de maneira geral a gente
tem que ser muito cuidadoso com isso tem
uma dimensão é
é aí que é muito importante e acho que
mesmo quando a gente pensa no processo
demencial mesmo quando o processo está
mais avançado e a pessoa está mais
deteriorada e mesmo quando esses
caminhos mais antigos não consciência de
que começa a se fechar
a gente ainda tem uma responsabilidade
ética porque a gente está ali e eu
queria justamente encerrar é nessa nota
né
com um poema é um poeta brasileiro sejam
se diz que escreveu isso o pai dele que
sofria de demência e que é justamente
sobre isso ele fala papai você perde a
memória mas não a minha
perdura obrigado